in israel there have been protests in
tel aviv and west jerusalem against the
government's handling of the coronavirus
pandemic
police used water cannon in west
jerusalem to try to disperse the crowds
israel reimposed restrictions after a
surge in cases last week
something that angered demonstrators
they've been protests for weeks
over the economic situation and lockdown
measures
also chance demanding prime minister
benjamin netanyahu resign
harry fawcett reports now from west
jerusalem
there are two simultaneous sizeable
protests going on
uh one here in west jerusalem close to
the prime minister's
residence uh where we are hearing
reports of water cannon being used again
of uh a large number of streets around
the residents being
sealed off in order to keep protesters
away and as you say this
other major protest in tel aviv and
there have been small protests
throughout the country there are those
who are protesting as part of a
long-term campaign against benjamin
netanyahu on the grounds
of wanting to get rid of a prime
minister who is also
facing trial under trial in three
corruption cases but the numbers have
been very much
buttressed and swollen by people who are
protesting against the economic fallout
of the pandemic the protests in tel aviv
are largely or at least they've been
talked about as protesters
from the communities of small business
owners of restaurant owners
because they feel that they are unduly
bearing the burden
of the shutdowns that have been taking
place as you say the restrictions
imposed last week
further restrictions imposed just a
couple of days ago
including beaches to be closed from next
week all non-essential shops and malls
to be shut down
during weekends gatherings restricted to
10
indoors and 20 in open spaces but they
also
plan to shut down all restaurants from 5
pm on friday
there was a revolt from restaurant
owners who said they'd already bought
all of the
perishable goods for this weekend the
government reversed itself on that
because it was afraid
apparently of the kind of street
protests and
and public disorder that could have
resulted from
from that